Louisville police
shot and
killed Breonna Taylor.
The deadly shooting
of Philando Castile.
Stephon Clark
killed by police.
Fifty shots.
Six officers opened fire.
George Floyd!
Around the United States
there is outrage.
Enough is enough,
but it's been enough.
Black communities
have a deep rooted fear
of being treated
unfairly by police.
A black man has twice
the odds of being pulled over
compared to a white man.
To say, “I can't breathe”,
it's not as though he
didn't try to communicate.
What is it gon’ take?
I'm mad as hell!
Today's political climate
has carried on the tradition
of protecting those
who have been accused
of excessive use of force.
Don't be too nice.
I'll tell you what
freedom is to me.
No fear!
There have been
more protests than
the whole last
period of civil rights.
It's not enough to just watch it
and be upset about it.
We have to come up
with a solution.
We look at what the community
is asking of us.
What do we have to lose...
by actually doing
something different?
No justice!
No peace!